so liebe zuschauer wir unterbrechen die
sendung für einen kurzen programmhinweis
die folgenden sendungen verzögert sich
um zirka 86 cent sachsen anhalt ein
bundesland das ist eigentlich nur gibt
damit sich das saarland nicht so
unwichtig fühlt hat im alleingang die
für januar geplante erhöhung des
rundfunkbeitrags auf eis gelegt
ministerpräsident reiner haseloff holt
damit die kuh von eben diesem sport
spiel denn an den 86 cent wäre beinahe
seine kenia koalition verstorben
haseloff wahrscheinlich der liebste
landeschef den wir haben wird jetzt so
ein netter mann bei dem darf jede gez
rola einfach so ins büro einlassen
guten morgen herr haseloff viele termine
heute auf dem programm
wie seht ihr tag heute genau auf die
termine habe ich schon hinter mir
ein haupttermin auch gerade jetzt habe
ich post gemacht und noch ein gesetz
unterschrieben das wirkte jetzt zum
glück gar nicht gestellt
phoenix schlimmer als rtl 2 übrigens
kann der liebe rainer auch ganz anders
wie sein parteifreund holger stahlknecht
gerade schmerzhaft lernen musste
stahlknecht vom chef gefeuert weil er in
einem interview laut von einer cdu
minderheitsregierung in magdeburg
geträumt hat was de facto auf eine afd
tolerierung hinausläuft tabubruch
stahlknecht wollte haseloff wegputzen
jetzt ist er selber weg was sagt man
dazu
revier
bzw blöd im nachhinein innenminister
entlassen den innenminister
rausschmeißen wenn angela merkel erfährt
dass so was möglich ist
dabei hat er stark nicht vor jede
zusammenarbeit mit der afg immer strikt
abgelehnt er ist ja überhaupt ein mann
der klaren worte
da darf auch mal polarisiert werden das
gehört zu einer streitkultur zu einer
demokratie dazu
es muss endlich aufhören in dieser
gesellschaft dass wir uns gegenseitig
polarisieren sehr gute statement aber
auch sehr schlecht was sein bundesland
übrigens noch viel dringender bräuchte
als polarisierung wenn eine
rechtschreibreform
wenn ich mir angucke wie die sich hier
selber schreiben guck mal sachsen-anhalt
entschuldigung es geht um 86 cent aber
wohl auch um die frage wie weit offen
nach rechts agiert die cdu von sachsen
anhalt zitat aus einer denkschrift der
cdu-landtagsfraktion wir müssen das
soziale mit dem nationalen versöhnung zu
zählen national ist muss wo ist das
problem
unvergessen natürlich auch der
cdu-kreisvorsitzende mit dem hakenkreuz
tattoo hinter dem sich die partei erst
mal gestellt hat teile der sachsen
anhalts cdu sind halt anders und ich hab
da auch ein stück weit verständnis
überleg mal du sitzt da als cdu neben
einem heimlichen schwarm der afd
alle elf minuten verliebt sich ein cdu
mitglied aus sachsen anhalt in einer afd
stattdessen zwingt man die mit den
grünen zu regieren
mit denen kann man ihn über ausländer
reden und immer noch mal klima verdammte
körnerfresser innen tragisch wirklich
tragisch und weil haseloff weiß dass er
seinen eigenen verein nicht im griff hat
wurde die abstimmung zum
rundfunkstaatsvertrag in sachsen-anhalt
sicherheitshalber abgesagt jappy.de
jetzt klagen ard und zdf auf
gebührenerhöhung ja gebührenerhöhung
natürlich ein hochsensibles thema und da
ist es sage ich ehrlich schon wichtig
dass das wir vor allen dingen mit uns
selber sehr selbstkritisch in genau
selbstkritik hilft nur wenn sie sich
gegen ein selber richtet es wäre die
erste gebührenerhöhung seite 2009 unter
inflationsausgleich beschlossen von 1
unabhängigen kommission wie das üblich
ist meine natürlich sind die
öffentlich-rechtlichen längst der
lieblingsfeind von afg und co bekannt
die eigene seite redet immer von
zwangsgebühren die andere also wir etwas
zu aufgeblasen von demokratie abgabe
beiden möchte man zurufen hab das nicht
ein bisschen kleiner
ein gutes programm spricht doch für sich
selbst politmagazine dokus nachrichten
in pandemie / fake news zeiten wichtiger
denn je überzeugen kann man sowieso nur
mit qualität und nicht mit subtilen
drohungen ich glaube wir haben heute in
den diskussionen auch wirklich erörtert
nicht nur wir sondern die vielen vielen
sachverständigen von produzenten
wirtschaft und arbeitgeberverbände und
viele andere dass sachsen-anhalt
nachteile hätte wenn die
beitragsanpassung nicht käme im sinne
von schönes bundesland habt ihr hier
wäre doch schade wenn da keiner mehr
drüber berichtet dinge können kaputt
gehen ja sagen wir mal unglücklich
formuliert vom kölner wdr intendanten
wenn man darf natürlich stolz sein auf
das öffentlich rechtliche angebote und
muss sich gleichzeitig kritischen fragen
stellen warum gibt es noch keine
gemeinsame mediathek von ard und zdf
warum läuft in der primetime
hauptsächlich programm für gut
abgehangene zuschauer reichen 20 lineare
tv sender und über 70 hörfunkwellen
könnte man nicht viel mehr
synergieeffekte nutzen
warum nicht erfolgreiche formate einfach
zusammenlegen
zum beispiel weil sie nicht das
traumschiff und den bergdoktor ja
und das nennt man dann der werkstoff
doktor wie schön das ist die sokos
potsdam münchen köln hamburg wismar
stuttgart wien kitzbühel und leipzig
gibt aber was könnte man sparen mit
einer serie soko irgendeine stadt oder
bares für rares quoten kracher genau wie
das heute journal
warum nicht zu einer show verschmelzen
[Musik]
für diesen hässlichen schinken gibt 100
euro und das ärgert schon wieder 20.000
neuinfektionen
schöne scheiße mit den zweiten spannt
man besser super oder eine heute-show
royal
das drama von sachsen-anhalt beweist
doch vor allem eins die cdu leidet unter
einem akuten machtvakuum
spätestens nächstes jahr schlittert die
arme partei so in eine krise und ich
finde da muss man den schwarzen auch mal
helfen
herzlich willkommen zum black nose day
unserer charity gala im zdf präsentiert
von tina hausten
guten abend und herzlich willkommen zum
black nose day liebe zuschauer öffnen
sie ihre herzen und helfen sie bitte der
cdu einer völlig orientierungslosen
volkspartei ich habe das mal gegoogelt
die waren wohl mal konservativ was sie
heute sind das ja keine ahnung
rufen sie jetzt an und sagen sie uns was
ist konservativ und sagen sie uns auch
ob vielleicht die wehrpflicht wieder
eingeführt werden soll oder soll man ist
doch wieder verbieten dass schwule
lesben heiraten dürfen
rufen sie an und spenden sie so der cdu
ideen themen oder noch viel dringender
spenden sie bitte neue vorsitzende
werden ganz nötig gebraucht wie soja
doch accadis doch noch gut weil ich
bitte sie dass das ist doch lächerlich
die krise der sachsen anhalts cdu oder
wie wir sie scherzhaft nennen der as a
cdu hat auch bewiesen wie führungslos
der laden ist und die liebe ak hat nun
mal leider 0 autorität der einzige der
sich von ihr noch führen lässt dass er
hier
und selbst der hat keinen bock mehr
nächstes jahr wenn frau merkel weg ist
dann kommt das große elend
[Musik]
und der läuft eine spende ein per tweet
werden uns gleich zwei neue vorsitzende
angeboten von einer gewissen spd norbert
und saskia cow gebraucht und stubenrein
ja vielen dank ganz lieb gemeint aber so
verzweifelt sind die auch wieder nicht
entschuldigung ist kandidieren doch
gerade drei top typen für den
cdu-vorsitz stimmt da war doch was genau
oliver aber keiner von den drei top
kandidaten holt in bundesweiten umfragen
zur kanzler tauglichkeit mehr als 30
prozent
komisch das sind doch so schillernde
persönlichkeiten wir wandern viel wir
lieben unsere heimat das sauerland dann
unternehmen wir was sind entweder nur
zusammen gehen raus und siebengebirge
neben den hund mit spazieren wandern
ich gucke gerne fernsehen gerne tatort
und lese gerne faszinierend hobbys
reiten schwimmen lesen aber keiner von
denen hat leider eine antwort auf die
inhaltliche leere der cdu das programm
war merkel
die hört aber auf und der letzte
markenkern die schwarze null geht dann
corona durch den schornstein bedenken
sie nur wer da kommt wenn die nicht ganz
ganz bald einen halbwegs brauchbaren
kanzlerkandidaten hinten drei kandidaten
und wer weiß ob es bei den drei bleibt
ist ja alles möglich in diesen zeiten
was man so liest ja so viel subtiler
kann man sich nicht selber ins spiel
bringen markus söder
das wären vier jahre ununterbrochene
pressekonferenzen zum thema wie geil ist
bitte kanzler söder
deswegen bitte helfen sie und jetzt
kommen wir zum showteil bei bled nose
day und natürlich haben wir um ihre
gebühren zu schonen hier wieder kosten
und mühen gescheut liebe zuschauer hier
kommt für rund 30 euro fahrtgeld die
putzfrau von helene fischer
[Musik]
sein
ja it-service bruns ich spreche mit
jürgen wie kann ich ihnen weiterhelfen
ja haben sie mal versucht das gerät aus
und wieder einzuschalten hat nichts
gebracht verstehe
probieren sie doch mal den kanal der
heute show auf youtube zu abonnieren
und im zweifel ruhig auch mal den
gefällt mir -button klicken
genau ja ich bleibe in der leitung